this is the emergency evacuation
announcement which are now read and it
starts with please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded should we
be required to evaporate a building
would you please leave the room by the
door to the fire escape staircase please
help both handrails in case the stairs a
little slippery as you know if anyone is
unable to use the stairs would they
please allow others to exit the room
before they go to the fire escape door
where they can then be given assistance
fire assembly point will be in the
public car park at the side of the Civic
sweet please do not delay your
evacuation to text me belongings please
do not return to the building until
given permission to do so by council
stops then move on to apologies for
absence there on up not members attend
in counselor so I'm Smith yes minutes of
the meeting held on 28th man in but 2014
can also next minutes Murray yes so
you're here yes when I say we are mainly
or maybe the 27th tourism husband cozy
otherwise we rule in the wrong place to
receive declarations of interest none
they are move on to the treasury
management strategy statement annually
investment strategy and minimum revenue
provision policy statement 2015 16 and
they're considering the heading liam
reformed hair finance on the house's
treasury strategy of baroda investments
i'll stop at positive caster Smith wants
to say anything if only moved to members
asking questions the statement that you
see is pretty much in line with Walt
done for the good number of years and
the the principles that we do within it
have served as quite well but clearly
circumstances change figures change
projections change and so on and you see
the various estimates through through
the report we've not had I'm not had any
significant concerns and in reality i
think that the quality of performance
that our management has given us has
been something to be reasonably proud
about the pin a number of issues
nationally internationally over the
cross years with banks countries but all
sorts of things happening they haven't
really hit us at all
and we've we've taken a sidestep
recently with our banking because the
co-op has started going to draw we've
managed to get out without any issues
turtle oide and of course the one thing
that we are particularly proud of is
that we have no borrowing at all and
we're still in this position despite the
valley activist council of the earth and
investments pushing investments have
have been made in the capital and and so
on that's just a very very brief outline
of how I'm saying it thank you i will
now see if anyone has any questions but
we'll stop YK they're not over that one
oh so am i right there generac don't
mind i should just say that we obviously
before I took over the the portfolio and
the management was managed equally well
by one of your fellow it's free perhaps
an international acclaim yes so as soon
as they could say yes I concur with many
of those comments I think to pray also
be given to certain football fans who
have kept us out at Fiasco in the
Icelandic banking crisis and principe
buyers of reading the back pages of the
late winter and that was one of the
things which I seem to recall and shed a
little bit actor critic but I think most
must go to our finance team and I
suppose in terms of the generalities of
the
or oh that was something which i think
is possibly under consideration to
actually finance potential revenue
streams from asset purchases or
developments of some sort but it is that
very much within the portfolio Lord is
thinking while we we've got a need for
financing at saying that or a 3.2 page
30 years where we've got some some
rejections but for some financing we do
because of all the different finance
streams that that we handle have have
reasonable cash flows and we've been
able to do some internal borrowing
essentially up to now but your ride
while interest rates are low on
borrowing money isn't desperately
expensive so there is a an argument that
if you borrow while the money's cheap
even if you might not immediately need
it it could still make good financial
sense the estimates going forward though
are suggesting that borrowing could
perhaps the manor at lower levels and
then the other thing that we've we've
got is options as to how we borrow what
the public were
loans board but they've also being
investigating and game as one of Reno's
susu performance agency which it's not
it's not set up yet but there's there's
potentially an alternative there as well
so following is not written out at this
moment in time and clear and potentially
there is a need there is a need into the
future but whether that is external
borrowing or not it's not been
determined yet but I think cap the lead
officer if I'm word word has sort of
being dropping hints to members that you
know that that question needs to come up
a discussion visions in the downside of
the poem works loadable is that although
you can lock in relatively low rates
currently for quite a considerable
period if if if required I believe it
has to be used virtually he well not
necessarily immediately in this very
short term he has to be actually for a
project whereas when the sort of bonds
financing route it wouldn't necessarily
be tied in or tied down in such a way
was that question anyone answering
altered state until I bro hello you're
wasting party statement hard question i
think it really is it is d probably
judging by the North i was getting it
that i think i'll probably right yes
with my state before the time they will
not and you just go far with the puppet
works bodies can you confirm that those
loans the you come up or you can't repay
the money but the interest be charged in
full or is that not that loan I'm not
sure I don't know Elsa I find out okay
cousin my time here we've never borrow
yes yeah I'm sorry I'm no usable
solution and know that I'll do for both
yeah that is just I met you and this was
also if they occupied if so I hold you
to that please don't I just want to stay
on this particular issue because I've
highlighted 3.2 as well where the CFR
doesn't infer that there's a borrowing
requirement I want to ask a number of
questions it's about the practicalities
and deciding of things and then I want
to ask other questions about capital
receipts in particular I want to ask
well we have this report and we're
carrying forward a barbarian requirement
which is actually quite soon so in terms
of the rules is it entirely acceptable
for us to report this position and yet
have taken no definitive action so I
guess my question is going to be what
action would need to be taken to fulfill
a borrowing to leave this sea of our
deficits when would it need to be taken
how will it need to be taken and who
needs to be involved but i'll talk about
other issues whether you mentioned table
3.2 lee the 1 million eight hundred and
six thousand is for the waste vehicles
that are being procured now the
procurement process has started it's my
understanding that we pay for those
vehicles in mine so in the 2015-16
financial year and sits in the 2015-16
column in terms of how quickly we can
take out loan if we go down that route
from the pw lb let's say oh I understand
is that so that's a fairly quick process
I believe it can be done in a matter of
days I don't think it's literally a form
filling exercise that is passed on to
the tech pwl me and then turned around
pretty quick I have to confirm that
black that's my understanding of it okay
thanks for that but of course learn as
an answer the whole of my question
because I asked about how and who you've
told me about when eppley given a
comfort about how that can be organized
but what process do we need to go
through in Council always counsel not
involved at all is it purely a portfolio
elders decision again my understanding
is it would be a recommendation from the
head of finance at that time they will
see a bottom won't be with us invite so
that will be the section 151 officer
forever be in place and in terms of
whether it comes before full council and
portfolio I'll think its portfolio
holder whether the spending decisions
already been made on the waist vehicles
to allow the yeah they are the item to
be the order to be placed and so on but
each each subsequent year those spending
figures are there based on our five year
spending plan but the spending plan
comes to council each with the capital
program as well as well obviously stop
start to look at you look at those next
week isn't it where you start to look at
the budget and that'll have the capital
program attached to that so ultimately
it is a council decision so okay getting
it right in my mind them for these
meetings then we're expecting council to
confirm that a borrowing should be made
externally to me this CFR so that's our
anticipation and I think the the borough
of work the route of borrowing is
undecided or involved on Saturday
remember the yday intimating that the
1.8 million would hopefully be
internally burrowed but there's no
guarantee of that she intimated that the
future year 16 17 17 18 would probably
be when we need to externally all right
but the agreement of this report would
be agreeing that i thought the boring
would need to take place i agree what
you say chairman in july yes but i think
it would really miss of this review
committee not to anticipate what the
future may hold in terms of individual
particle decisions because if we don't
and we miss something are not asking
questions we will be held reasonably
accountable by the prayer for not having
done so anticipated what should happen
next so I'm uncomfortable if the process
based on my questions is is limited
which shows that the review committee
we're aware of the circumstances we're
entering into and how the councillors
balanced budget would be fulfilled
particularly around the capital
see so it's a case this is a case of of
being careful and assured which is of
course the responsibility more scrutiny
communities they clearly they the
borrowing requirement is Bob the
spending requirement is part of that the
greater budget which is balanced and how
we make the payments that we can afford
it and so on within the way things
operate when that payment comes due to
be made the anticipation is that we'll
be able to find that capital receipt in
turn later to do the boring if there is
the need to externally borrow a
proportion of it or or whatever I
couldn't tell you exactly now what what
the precise procedure is but we can
weaken furnish you with with with our
procedure well I don't believe that
decision to borrow or not to borrow will
come to counsel it's the principle of
the spending that's the result of yes I
i knows that but yes for the purpose of
the minutes and revising honestly I
think it would be helpful to have the
procedure set out so that it's known
beforehand particularly with you know
consider amount of change going on in
the council and in particular around the
15 mile over said particularly I think
it would be useful guide for a 1.1
officer coming online Ainger in to know
the council is actually thought about it
and set it down there's too many other
things think about so I ignited
everything you say knowledge that you
know there is a plan there is an
acknowledgement there is an expectation
but that's a final expectation in the
event that we hang on to a position
where we we weren't able to for
something
that happened that we don't honestly
know about finance is notorious for
spinning things upon us that was
expecting and I think as the Seekers
would agree that there's something of
prudence E but the public nurse should
think about I've done that and of course
is a as we move forward there are
potential capital receipts from
decisions that have all haven't been
made which can obviously influenced well
I'm very said that because that's where
I was going next I was really glad that
you anticipated what I was going to say
next there is that there is that there
are references in the report to cabin
receipts and whether or not asset sales
will will turn out to be so or in the
amount required to what extent what I
sets are there what I what I say it's
always selling and what's the present
view on whether they will yield a
capital receipt in this time scope I
don't know that definitive decisions
about our assets have been made as
you're aware there are talks and
discussions about the yard you know the
depo bastard to what what's happening
there we've got another another another
number of properties that were looking
at the viability of we're looking at the
use of them we're not looking to strip
assets or anything like spiral on all
management of the resources that we've
got making sure that they are
efficiently used if if we're not using
them other other agencies that use them
is it best to dispose of them what's the
viability and where we've all properties
the whole lot is is constantly reviewed
not on a weekly or monthly basis a being
a periodic basis but there are not
there's not a whole line of definitive
sell-offs that are in the pipeline and
there's a lot of decisions and processes
to go through before things like that
happen as they say when I was in finance
cuttings books no okay that's less fun
to me okay in a question if we don't ask
presented with the position in front of
us we will miss your personal to do to
to ask the extent of planning for it
because when there's a statement that
says it may or may not happen you're
bound to ask well what may or may I have
so whenever I'll sort of this point they
did you okay thinking carefully Thank
You vision and I had to say that i found
the report to a quite comprehensive and
involved and council Mason has raised a
number of points that I want to write a
thank you video and the pleasure always
been interested as mentioned earlier on
Saturday maybe one mentioned the the
possibility of us lending from ourselves
which I feel quite an interesting
concept but as with all the lumps the
interest rate ER we say the interest
rates are going to go up if you two
years or if we are going to have to for
our money the best thing to do I think
earlier rather than later but also I
don't know there's going to be a new
section 151 officer and they may take a
different me on everything as well so
there's perhaps something else we need
to consider for the future but overall I
thought the report very comprehensive I
was pleased to note the obviously we you
habiter to which we use a certain
financial information on the day-to-day
basis we don't take their in their
advice
thinking about it ourselves which i
think is a good positive thing as well
and that was a good to see move forward
well that's why I am is generally then
what does the past about benchmarking
yes obviously we use capital to what we
use their advice of our investments and
when we pay the minimum amount for the
poor that I was looking for details
about benchmarking for similar councils
rotten seeing the report on Mount missed
it we may be called something different
probably wondering if it's possible
expansion one place on the council see
if our returns a similar to this this
this was a question that came up at the
los gasket fishery and following that
meeting i emailed all about my captain's
other authorities and i do have set
because here in front of me tonight and
it's not a comprehensive table of the
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten 11 of the 13 or 30s i emailed
sorry over the 12 13 including us i've
only had one two three four five
responses i can give you those responses
but i didn't want to give you part
information go would you like um i can
read them out if you read the day okay
well in terms of the mail go with the
most recent quarter our average interest
rate return that the one thing to bear
in mind is some of these or thirties use
fund managers whereas we don't we do all
the Treasury investments ourselves our
average interest rate return was not
point six eight percent for court
three is it okay to men take this him
for other authorities is that I shared
between the public information it's what
well hey Matt our report the midterm on
tells the interest rate they should all
be doing the same okay so I'm assuming
it's public information okay Castle
Point North Point for one percent
chelmsford one-point-four percent but
that came with the caveat that they have
three long-term investments that they
put out five years ago got just maturing
which were very high rates finding by
the internet and they admitted that when
they mature they'll be much nearer
outfit is molding no point five seven
percent southend-on-sea didn't give me
quarter three but the nearest ahead was
called to north point for eight percent
and utter Swift nor point three four
percent so you can see from those
figures that we are punching well above
everybody apart from chomps with Bob's
do with their their caveat that they've
got longer investments so I think for
for the small portfolio that we have it
it's definitely doing well up on the
results we have back so far I will be
pestering these other authorities that
haven't come back and fill you in as
soon as I come back to me they've
written for it it's good work I don't
have anything is in front of me but I
can recall similar statistics been given
last year's as well no I had concerns
about with we were may be overcautious
be more suggests to me that it would pop
you're now right in our strategy it's
it's one of the things when I meet with
Yvonne on a six monthly basis with
our relationship manager at capture and
it's one of the things he always
commences for Venice oral 30 years is
the local relationships we have with the
banks we do use to get a good rates that
we're getting here he's quite impressed
compared to these other authorities
across the county could you do the G cos
employ people yet nor point for oneness
of all right okay 30 is 14 that's a guy
right very good actually don't really
have any other questions has anyone else
but to be able to forget the trailer
thank you for the comment regards to
capital i remember in previous
discussions do we asked if we could
investigate with capita as to whether
they could do more for us in did we get
the response i think it was within the
sixth day i think they face we played up
six days of this hasn't known but don't
hear we got the response to that
question I didn't want got a response to
a slightly different I think great we
denounce I think the question was
possibly before they came and did a
training session I'm not sure if any of
you attended that train session in
October where our relationship manager
actually came in took two sessions here
on specifically on treasury management
entrepreneurs ill right but I think he
was going to address any any questions
like that chip in his presentation and I
think that question will be relevant to
cursor speak naturally was I think
finding the advice might be but because
we have the basic service from them for
6,000 pounds of is whether or not
additional monies might increase our
return although superficially would see
we get Polly would return anyway there
to announce origins but they may not
have it at my vary between no advice at
all yeah or tiny Joseph on the surface
6,000 pounds is it quite quite quite a
lack of money from with interest rates
in lower the differential in your return
to make it worthwhile that has to be
considerable in years past with our
interest rates I think we would agree
one hundred thousand yeah we've had over
a hundred thousand back in in past years
well then you can look at much more
significant investments in your advice
and so on but I'm probably reasonably
comfortable with where we are at the
moment we haven't got lots of money and
I thought I think our risk that we're
taking at the my don't think we're being
over overcautious being sensible and
fairly rise it's 11 16 which has got
those sort of profile of the things that
we do and i think i think that there's
also a danger that you could lose
something if you're passing too much
over capital as well because we're
actually making the investments
ourselves so actually that's quite a lot
of skill and expertise that were
developing in the understanding of money
in the handling about yeah i mean that's
not my my absolute expert ariel although
i'm not a working professional in it my
you know some of you gentlemen have been
thumb and i think that that that
upskilling that we're getting from that
and that the sudden walk-ons is actually
very useful to us as an organization as
a council but it's very difficult to
quantify in terms of a value can i just
also point you to 11.20 which is
something yvonne wanting me to highlight
if this question came up there we very
obviously this will be after everyone's
departure but whoever is the 151 officer
will be looking at
45 via capita which I don't know what
the outcome will be in terms of you but
that may well be an opportunity where's
opportunity to look in another area
other than our standard banks and
building societies 'um and bonds etc
thank you I'm sorry counselor Mason's
integrated I'm glad you picked up on
that point because it was one that i
left for later if you see the lake yes I
I'd like to know more about that because
that could be configured and I'm sure
cancer singers you know we'll probably
know more than I do but property funds
could be configured in different ways
and you know they can make the funding
cell phone can be configured you know
above the property in the property as so
aside the property indices and all sorts
of things they could be onshore offshore
are all sorts of different flavors so I
don't know what they can offer there so
i would like to ask for them to provide
us with a briefing I don't think I'm
gonna like it let's do it like a
briefing
I will and I'll ask Avon to tailor
fatigue us okay I'm just finishing off
that point of course property has to be
looked at as being a very much a longer
to them investment in most instances but
going back to some gaining additional
services from capita then I think it's
important though he sort of note that
our balances will actually be somewhat
lower for the time being and therefore
paying extra monies to get that to last
fraction % as it would be at the moment
and is probably not in a good bet and
good investment in so I think we did
discuss the the the additional services
and that was the view i took at the time
and i think that we would potentially
pay a lot for and not a great deal lot
extra for not a great deal more in the
evening what we got back relative to
what seems to me everything most of this
concur it was a pretty good deal at
6,000 pounds I don't know how long it
will stay at that might change Burton
it's a five-year contract which was
taken out in january 2014 and the only
add is inflation every year oh so
there's not going to be that's a red
beans ESMA 200 this year he's a ship yo
Rocky on she got me out that's ok let's
open sea getting big difference would
you mind if I ask another person is a
very question sorry I I recognize the
answer that said that we made me out to
borrow internally
which of course is a welcome thing
because obviously it saves you from
paying interest is there any way within
within our accounting or even our
reporting at the very least we can
actually you know reflect a notional a
notional benefit of having done so
because that in fact it enhances our
return if you like in the performance of
the management of our puns and I think
that would that would be an appropriate
way of expressing how wise that is to do
or we can put I could add a table into
the report to show potential costs at
different pwl be borrowing rates is
unmissable well I guess what I'm saying
is if we were to borrow it and pay
interest yeah if we actually bar
internally I don't know what the cost of
funds internally is there may be across
the funds I don't know how we actually
yes structure things I would probably
have a notional you know internal cost
but the earlier they'll be a kind of
innate and that's on what you would have
paid against what you fought for for
went or paid in terms of the cost of
funds internally but in but in fact they
would be a benefit and that benefit
should be of credit to the management
team so I'm I'm suggesting that if we
can't show in a pure accounting way
which I suspect we calm because behind
notional you know but in a reporting
sense I think it would do well for us to
report it okay when you say credit to
the management team you'd only bonuses
they honour notices how was it but you
know as I driving feeling just to add to
that mean other any circumstances where
for instance we could take a loan
on the interest for instance we will get
some sort of tax relief or some other
type of relief that would perhaps negate
us having to do this internal right just
a question of them but I know about I
have a live I have a feeling that's
cheating or rather than I loud yeah I
put up pretty fitting that's called
arbitrage and you'd be probably drummed
out of every opportunity in the future
as well as probably find yourself sorry
silence Kobe you facing the music summer
I have to so readily admit you in for
the tape and the term arbitrage is what
not one that fits into my normal
category but essentially what it is you
borrow at one rate and you lend it back
to a market at a high rate arbitrage you
can't do arbitrage but even taking a tax
advantage would be a form of arbitrage
and I think they were probably for
somehow into the wrong category looking
no return we're not allowed to borrow to
invest so I guess are based on those
guidelines like except indirectly by
actually investing in elastic which
produces a revenue stream if we can
finance those refuse romantic vehicles
cheaper than the current contractors can
borrow or future contractors can do so
well get that actually saves us or
non-revenue fire which you start of the
other thinking was a degree of security
because it's it's not unknown the way
steam tractors go bust whatever happens
you can't collect the mendon's if you
have our vehicle it's really we can
labor can be bought the vehicles they're
more difficult
as we found with you a dragger aircraft
have failed my instance at one time yeah
they took all the secretary way and is
that it I don't think I body in
particular questions on there might be
something that the first copies I are
printed off themselves to read through
unfortunately just to the end of the
toner cartridges little bits and finds
as I at least I remind on white like
that and so removal to the
recommendations are 18 and then famine
face baccarat gratifying page 5.1 right
yep for taking separate your fingers for
cavity so item one we note the treasury
management strategies statement and
annual investment strategy including the
investment is investment instruments
indicated limits and delegations
contained within revolt know that have
to expenditure forecasts note the MRP
policy for 2015-16 mount the authorized
limit and operational boundary for
external debt as laid down in this
report are we have power over those so
far yes the Senate Yemen the next one is
slightly different identify any issues
on this topic for further consideration
and discussion by the committee well we
did that in the sense that we've asked
question yep and the minute we'll show
show your answers exactly I'm contempt
yeah so the minutes will show so that
one that's good and we recommend the
content of this report to the full
council yes yes very meeting closed they
promote their